problema número 227 del siguiente
sistema coordenada cuál es la ecuación
de l l es esta línea que pasa por acá y
viendo este diagrama a ojo podemos
darnos cuenta que el pasa por el eje y
en el punto 2 aquí está pasando esta
línea y este punto tiene las coordenadas
cero porque x vale 0
0,2 y también pasa en este punto del eje
x que es 12 el punto 3 así que este otro
punto de la línea es el
300 porque ya vale 0 acá está justo
sobre el eje x recordemos que para la
fórmula de la línea vamos a necesitar
encontrar la pendiente y la pendiente de
una línea m se define como el cambio en
g entre el cambio en x vamos a tomar
este punto de aquí para encontrar la
diferencia entre estos dos puntos tengo
que y aquí es cero y aquí es 2 así que
esta diferencia de iu es 0 - 2 de aquí
acá y ahora la diferencia en x siempre
teniendo el cuidado de tomar el primer
punto que elegimos con la coordenada y
para también que sea el primer punto con
la coordenada x si no nos va a quedar
una pendiente negativa a la que es
realmente aquí es 73 - aquí la aie de
acá es 0 3 - 0 esto es 0 - 2 - 23 menos
0 que da 3 menos dos tercios esta es la
pendiente cuál es el valor de esta
ecuación cuando x es igual a 0 bueno
aquí esta recta cuando x es igual a 0 va
a valer 2 de cero es igual a 2 y ahora
si con esto podemos armar nuestra
ecuación de la línea les recordamos que
es
igual a la pendiente que es menos dos
tercios por equis más la intersección en
ya más dos pero en las opciones que nos
dan nos están pidiendo que esta ecuación
esté en el formato x más bella igual
hace vamos a modificar esto para dejarlo
de esa forma voy a multiplicar todo por
33 ye igual a menos 2 x más 2 12 x en
ambos lados me va a quedar 2 x + 3g
igualados ahora si la tengo en el
formato que me piden y esto corresponde
a la opción b muy bien siguiente
problema problema número 228 si a un
entero positivo de dos dígitos se le
invirtieron los dígitos
el anterior resultante difiere del
original por 27 cuanto difieren a y b
bueno a qué me refiero con ahí ve voy a
expresar este entero positivo de dos
dígitos que no sé qué valor tiene como
ave y b son dígitos diferentes y me
dicen que si yo invierto estos dígitos
de manera que me que debe a la
diferencia entre ellos dos va a ser de
27 suponiendo que la diferencia es
positiva entonces ab tiene que ser más
grande que vea por lo que a va a tener
que ser más grande que b y al hacer la
resta de estas unidades al ser menor que
a vamos a tener que pedirle prestado a
la de las decenas una decena para ver de
manera que me va a quedar b más 10 y de
este otro lado pues me va a quedar a
menos uno entonces si vemos la parte de
las unidades nos va a quedar b más 10
que es esto - y va a ser igual a 7 que
es esto y de las decenas me va a quedar
que a menos uno menos b va a ser igual a
2 vamos a simplificar estas ecuaciones
este de acá resto 10 en ambos lados y me
va a quedar b menos o igual a 7 menos 10
-3 y si multiplico todo por menos 1 me
va a quedar a menos de 3 ok para que
verifiquemos que esto es verdadero
tenemos que encontrar esta misma
relación aquí abajo vamos a despejar
esto vamos a sumar 1 en ambos lados de
esta ecuación me va a quedar a menos b
igual a 2 más 13 muy bien justo me quedo
la misma expresión quiere decir que esto
está bien la diferencia entre a y b es
de 3 y corresponde a mi opción a
siguiente problema número 229 el
siguiente círculo es tangente a ambos
ejes si la distancia de cero aze es k
cuál es el radio del círculo en términos
de que la distancia del origen al centro
del círculo
de distancia creo que aquí vamos a usar
triángulos y se me ocurre viendo cómo
está este diagrama en dibujar una línea
vertical que vaya del centro del círculo
al eje x de manera que al llegar al eje
x me formé un ángulo recto aquí 90
grados y aquí tengo un triángulo
rectángulo bueno necesito conocer estos
lados para poder encontrar el valor de
acá y después encontrar el valor del
radio necesito usar el teorema de
pitágoras pero cuál es el valor de estos
lados bueno si se fijan esta línea que
acaba de poner en azul que va del centro
del círculo y está tocando justamente
uno de los puntos de la circunferencia
esto es un radio esto es r ese es un
radio del círculo y nada más me faltaría
encontrar el valor de este lado del
triángulo pero que creen como este
círculo es tangente a ambos ejes esta
línea de acá si yo la pongo aquí arriba
me va a quedar
justamente en este y es un radio esto es
r
y ahora sí ya tenemos estos valores que
me hacían falta y puedo encontrar que
aplicamos el teorema de pitágoras el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que la
suma del cuadrado de los lados de un
triángulo es igual al cuadrado de la
hipotenusa que se está encuadrada más r
cuadrada es igual a k al cuadrado
sumamos estos dos r al cuadrado es igual
a k al cuadrado dividimos todo entre 2
el re cuadrado igual acá al cuadrado
entre 2 sacamos la raíz cuadrada de todo
y me queda acá entre raíz cuadrada de 2
y esta es mi opción ve muy bien esto
estuvo bastante rápido
problema número 230 en un circuito
eléctrico dos registros con resistencias
xy están conectados en paralelo cierre
es la resistencia combinada de xy
entonces el recíproco de r es igual a la
suma de los recíprocos de x y ya cuál es
el valor de r en términos de xy ya han
de saber que esto de que la suma de los
recíprocos de las resistencias es igual
al recíproco de la resistencia combinada
es uno de los principios fundamentales
de las resistencias vamos a expresar
esto gráficamente aquí voy a dibujar una
resistencia que está no sé en base x
aquí abajo va a estar otra resistencia
que es que iban a estar conectadas en
paralelo es decir van a estar unidas de
esta forma en el circuito y la
resistencia combinada la voy a llamar r
me dicen que el recíproco de la
resistencia combinada es igual a la suma
del recíproco d
y veamos si podemos dejar r en términos
de xy ya bueno vamos a encontrar un
factor común denominador de estas esto
es igual a denominador xy aquí arriba
debo de tener de este lado para que se
conserve la proporción más de este lado
debo de tener x y esto es igual a 1
entre er ahora sacó el inverso en ambos
lados y me va a quedar que r es igual a
x porque entre x +
muy bien y ya tengo r en términos de
estas resistencias esta es mi opción de
muy bien vamos muy rápido veamos el
siguiente problema social yolanda y psoe
tratan de resolver un problema por
separado si sus probabilidades de éxito
son un cuarto un medio y cinco octavos
respectivamente
cuál es la probabilidad de que soy útil
y yolanda lo resuelvan pero psoe no
anotemos los datos son yolanda y soy sus
probabilidades de resolver el problema
es un cuarto medio y cinco octavos lo
que me piden es ver la probabilidad o
encontrar la probabilidad de que estas
dos se cumplan pero esta no como lo voy
a hacer podemos explicar las
probabilidades que quiero que se cumplan
un cuarto por un medio y aquí tengo que
encontrar el complemento a esto si esta
es la probabilidad de que soy resuelva
el problema esto lo tengo que restar a
la unidad para encontrar la probabilidad
de que esto no ocurra si mi unidades 8
entre 8 y 8 - cinco octavos la
probabilidad de que soy no resuelve el
problema es de tres octavos y ahora sí
multiplicó todo esto me va a quedar a 4
por 2 88 por 8 64 3 por 1 por 1 es 3
364 y vaya justamente esto tengo como
opción y muy bien con este problema
terminamos el vídeo de hoy y nos vemos
en el siguiente